thank you to target for supporting pbs
you would not be watching me here
on youtube if it wasn't for the zombie i
first saw night of the living dead
and scooby-doo on zombie island around
when i was
eight which was either a questionable
parenting choice or the best one
ever and since then the idea of the
reanimated corpse
fascinates me and yes i recognize the
potential red flags here
i pursued my degree so that i could
study the undead
and wrote my dissertation about them and
now i'm going to take what i've learned
and dig
even deeper into the long and complex
history
of the zombie zombies can be broken down
into three significant types
and this october i'm dedicating an
entire episode for each one of our
undead friends
we'll talk about the origins of each of
these zombies throughout history
and uncover why the modern zombie
continues to hold such a special place
in our hearts
or should i say brains and along the way
i'll be talking to some experts to get
some special insight
this three-part youtube series will
culminate in a one-hour documentary
airing on pbs
so let's kick it off with the origin of
the entire zombie war
going all the way back to early west
african spiritual practices
i'm dr emily zarka and this is monstrum
you can't talk about the origins of the
zombie without talking about the
spiritual practice of vodou
vodou was practiced throughout the world
and the concept of the zombie was born
out of this religion
voodoo is different from vodou although
even now the lines between them are
consistently blurred in popular culture
while one could argue that vodu is the
precursor of voodoo
it's important to understand that they
are distinct and separate religions
but the original vodou zombie is a
zombie you might not recognize
we need to look back more than four
centuries to early african spiritual
practices
those legends originated in part from
people of west africa
when men women and children were
forcibly taken from their homes
enslaved and shipped around the world
the spanish shipped enslaved people to
the island of hispaniola as early as
1502.
in the 17th century the french began
establishing colonies on the island as
well
and by 1697 they had obtained control
over the western third
what is now haiti and named it san
domain
over the course of the 18th century
france established the trade settlements
of likai
and port-au-prince with the demand for
sugar tobacco spice and coffee in europe
rising
many enslaved africans ended up on
plantations in haiti where the crops
could grow in abundance
bolstering france's economy and becoming
crucial to its success as a world power
by the late 1780s san domain boasted
one-third of the total people of the
atlantic slave trade
and more than 90 percent of the island's
population was enslaved
the african people on san domain came
from vastly different geographic
cultural and spiritual backgrounds
forced together in haiti under the
horrors of slavery
they developed a new religion to unite
their often disparate
views beliefs and experiences
integral to the vodou religion is the
belief that the human body is merely
flesh manipulated by the two
spiritual elements that make up the soul
the tibonage and the grouponage
the tibonage also called the petiponage
is the part of the individual able to
contact spirits called loas
as well as memory authority and
consciousness
essentially it is their personality
their uniqueness
the grouponage controls the motor
functions of the body allowing it to
move and breathe
each of these elements can be stolen for
practitioners of vodou death is a
process that takes time
the soul takes days to move on after
death and until the process is complete
both parts of the soul are at risk of
wandering or even capture
this is where the zombie comes in while
the majority of vodu priests and
priestesses
use their ability to commune with and
influence the spirits in a positive way
a spiritual leader who uses their
talents for malicious intent
is often called a bokor however it's
important to note that
others like voodoo priest divine prince
tayameka
argue that bokor is a derogatory term
rooted in prejudice
it's assumed when you say all i've only
known it as negative
we're looking at haiti and the usage of
both core and haiti
which can be negative they promote
themselves in a very negative way
i wanted clear that i'm not trying to
represent haitian voodoo
that i'm indeed louisiana mississippi
delta
west african voodoo so that's another
reason why i
adopt and earn the right to use bokor
and so many words including voodoo were
bastardized once we got to
this side up these names these titles
these lineages
we still fight over them today
particularly in social media
regardless of what the malicious voting
practitioners are called
they are identified by their willingness
to trap that part of the soul that
houses free will
the tibornage in a bottle it was
believed that whoever possesses the
bottle
controls the body of a deceased person
many haitian and vodou practitioners
believe to this day that zombies are
real
albeit rare it's important to note
however that haitian zombies look
nothing like those seen in today's
popular culture
vodou zombies are simply shells mindless
workers with no emotions
no ability to feel pain completely
subservient to the whims of their master
they may be brought to this form by
administering a poison that causes them
to enter a coma-like state in which they
are
still alive but appear dead the victim
is passed off as a corpse
buried and then exhumed from the grave
as a zombie
zombification took root as an allegory
for colonialism
imperialism and oppression after all is
it not a threat worse than death
the idea that one soul could also be
enslaved and neither it nor the body
could be free
this is dr cody roberts an associate
professor who specializes in the history
of african americans in the u.s
and the intersection of black religions
such as voodoo
there's a notion that well in the slave
system
you have no power right your property
you're owned your master has complete
control of your destiny
but voodoo gives you the chance to exert
a power over your
your enslaver that you could that
there's no
social uh uh parallel for
the haitian practitioners of vodou did
not fear the zombie itself
as modern audiences fear the flesh
eating zombies who pursue them across
the silver screen and into their
nightmares
the haitian slaves were terrified of
becoming a zombie
voodoo is really a creation of
out of slavery and enslavement where
they try to strip away
ethnic groups what makes you unique what
makes you individual
you all just product and so that's where
it became
important from 1791 to 1804 enslaved
africans revolted against their french
oppressors
the violent uprisings eventually led to
the declaration of haitian independence
in 1804
and slavery was officially abolished
there in 1805.
vodou further evolved in the united
states when the practices of the
enslaved haitian people
brought to the states by french slave
owners during the haitian revolution
were subjected to new influences so the
voodoo came with them
the gumbo mix of west african tradition
with
indigenous tradition and of course with
those eurocentric traditions that we
in some cases were forced to take on but
eventually adopted
as sort of a color cover and a symbolic
represent
representation of something unique to us
with voodoo people want to put it all
into one box it has to be one thing
either this is authentic voodoo or it's
not authentic voodoo
if there are black people then this is
voodoo if they're white people that it's
not
if they're rich people then it doesn't
count if voodoo's only practiced by poor
people in haiti
i wish people understood that voodoo was
just as complicated
as every other american religion and
treated it that way
at the start of the 20th century the
zombie was still largely unknown to the
american public
but that all changed when in 1915 the
united states military
occupied haiti as american journalists
and marines returned from haiti
they brought stories of the island with
them including stories of the living
dead
their exaggerated interpretations of
haitian zombies
one infamous example is william
seabrook's sensational 1929 travelogue
the magic island
he described these dead men working as
expressionless
with blank eyes like that of a corpse
this is dr robin means coleman professor
and author of hor noir
seabrook is the one who really
i think brings this notion of voodoo
the vulgar voodoo v-o-o-d-o-o back to
the states
he claims that he has gone to haiti and
he has
watched this sort of
primal wicked lustful
um movement and dance and it's sensuous
and it's
uninhibited and and so you know this is
saying a little bit about seabrook too
and so this wasn't entirely out of the
scope of what we already had a taste for
so he's just expanding that and we
clearly had an
appetite for these kinds of stories
haiti came to be seen as a place of
black magic
the books and newspaper reports were bad
enough but america's perception of
voodoo and vodou got worse in 1932
with the release of the first
feature-length zombie movie
white zombie in which a love-sick man
obtains the object of his affections
by poisoning her and bringing her back
to life as a mindless zombie
all of these early films are about it's
really about lust it's about
love it's about someone who is
as yet untouchable and how can i get
this person
well what does this mean in the 19 teens
the 20s the 30s the 40s
when the thing that is moving about
in some ways uninhibited
is black it is important to note that
the first zombie
ever to grace the silver screen was not
black
neither was the bokor white zombie marks
the first
instance of white bodies being subjected
to zombification
that's the heightened threat so white
zombie is a great example of this
although there
isn't as much of an overt representation
of blacks as zombies right but there's
still this permeation that this evil the
wickedness of haiti comes out of voodoo
and has infected in fact even white
people
right who are are now zombies walking
around
white zombies release occurred the same
year that american pulp magazine
strange tales published the first zombie
narrative set in the united states
and where else a plantation just outside
of new orleans
the 1932 story the house and the
magnolias by august durlith not only
demonizes people from haiti it shows
lingering fears in america by
further emphasizing the horrors of
slavery as well as equating black bodies
with monstrosity
a painter from chicago visiting new
orleans discovers a beautiful old house
of white wood
buried in magnolias upon knocking on the
door he is confronted with a black woman
with a gray cast to her skin
and eyes like deep black pools
bottomless
inscrutable and yet at the same time
oddly dull
she remains mute despite his questions
staring at him
unmoving a beautiful creole woman
interrupts
and states that she is the niece of the
plantation owner
aunt abby whom she describes as a
haitian
who left the island some years ago she
grants him permission to paint the house
but on the conditions that he never
brings
anyone else to the plantation never
tells anyone he's there
and never gives aunt abby any indication
he's on the property
he is forbidden from going anywhere
inside the house besides the ground
floor
but his curiosity gets the best of him
and under the cover of darkness
he explores the house and its
surrounding land where he finds black
people working
the fields in utter silence after
pressuring aunt abby's niece
he learns from her that in haiti there
are many strange beliefs like the zombie
a dead man who has been brought
out of his grave and made to live again
and to work
aunt abby knows how to create these
zombies and keeps the slaves in the
cellars during the day
the niece says that if they are given
salt they will know they are dead and
will find their way back to their graves
the painter and the niece resolve to
free these people
they feed the zombies candy with salt
and one by one they
wail terribly and run off into the night
the next day the houses discovered
burned to the ground with aunt abby
inside
the newspapers report the discovery of
putrifried remains in the half open
graves of slaves
whose bodies had been stolen long years
ago
and the curious detail that the graves
had been half dug by bare fingers
as if dead hands seek the empty coffins
below
the blank stares of the first zombies in
literature and film
were like blank slates upon which white
americans could write their own
anxieties and
fears because in the 1930s you're
justifying jim crow
and segregation so much like you're
using race and religion to justify
occupation in haiti you're using
something similar to justify segregation
in new orleans
i would argue that the zombie mythology
and that notion of
black religion producing these
moral evils is tied to that notion of
race and backwardness and savagery
that is used to justify keeping black
people in the position you want them to
be in whether that be
a kind of neo-colonialism in haiti or
segregation in new orleans
the haitian zombie ceded revelants to a
more violent version of the
undead during the mid-20th century but
popular culture turned its attention
back to the original vodou
zombie in the 1980s in the serpent and
the rainbow
wade davis wrote about his travels to
haiti to study vodou
and the claims that its practitioners
were capable of creating
real zombies through the use of locally
developed poisons
davis claimed to have discovered two
zombie powders
one for causing the appearance of death
and the other for reviving the victim
he was able to obtain eight samples of
before powders
all of which he claimed included
tetrodotoxin
a psychoactive substance taken from a
unique puffer fish
however later scientific studies of
these samples showed little to no
tetrodotoxin present
so the jury's still out on that one i
don't discuss
it because one it is taboo it's
dangerous
that information is guarded
protected it's only shared
with those qualified to handle that
information
um so when you start talking about
zombies in the making of zombies
that's a tricky conversation davis book
sparked a renewed interest in vodu and
the original zombie
it had enough of a public impact that
wes craven directed a film adaptation
the movie aimed to prove that vodu was a
real religion or so craven claimed
but in reality vader was misrepresented
as the stuff of horror once again
again it makes it very difficult to
operate in these traditions
and feel your humanity is being
acknowledged
people will acknowledge the voodoo
before they acknowledge my humanity
and people acknowledge whether it be as
a fear of the voodoo
or their need of something that they
think the voodoo can provide
but they're still not humanizing me
or the tradition in a way that we see
every day
zombies may have their nascency in the
spiritual practices of the african
diaspora
but popular cultures very liberal
interpretations of the original idea
mutated the creature into something else
entirely
in the next episode we'll look at how
the enslaved body both in mind
spirit and soul became the flesh-eating
undead
i'll give you a hint they're coming for
you barbara
we'd like to thank target for being a
proud supporter of pbs
since the first target opened in 1962
their mission has been to help families
discover the joy of everyday life
in all 50 states target is dedicated to
being a good neighbor
and working with their communities and
partners to make life a little better
there are over 350
000 team members employed by target to
continue their mission every day
to learn more about target's commitments
you can check out target.com
community or click the link in the
description pbs is asking
you to share your stories experiences
and ideas on your life in america today
pbs american portrait is a nationwide
storytelling project
a chance to be seen and heard and to
give a glimpse into your own life
everyone has a story share yours at
pbs.org
american portrait speaking of we think
you should check out self-evident a new
show aimed entirely at making sense of
2020
hosted by our friends daniel bainbridge
from origin of everything
and ali matu from the psych show because
who better than a historian and
therapist to help guide us through this
very weird year
link in our description they're coming
for you babara
i wish he said it like that but we're
coming to get you barbara